Es sorprendente que algunos sean buenos estudiantes,
lideren clubes y equipos
e incluso sean voluntarios en sus comunidades,
pero comen detergente por un reto viral,
usan el celular mientras conducen y exceden la velocidad
se emborrachan y prueban drogas ilegales.
¿Cómo pueden tantos adolescentes ser tan hábiles, inteligentes y responsables
y, al mismo tiempo, tan descuidados y correr tantos riesgos?
Cuando tenía 16 años,
solía observar a mis compañeros, tanto en persona
como en las redes sociales,
y comencé a preguntarme por qué los jóvenes corrían tantos riesgos.
Parece que obtener un certificado del curso de lucha contra las drogas
no puede detenerlos.
(Risas)
Lo que más me llamaba la atención
era que cuanto más se exponían a estos riesgos perjudiciales,
les era más fácil correr más riesgos.
Esto me confundía,
pero también me generó mucha curiosidad.
Como alguien cuyo nombre
significa literalmente "explorar el conocimiento",
comencé a buscar una explicación científica.
Todos sabemos que los adolescentes de entre 13 y 18 años
tienden a correr más riesgos que los niños o los adultos,
pero ¿qué los hace tan atrevidos?
¿Se vuelven imprudentes repentinamente?
¿O están atravesando una etapa natural?
Los neurocientíficos ya han encontrado pruebas
de que el cerebro adolescente todavía no ha madurado
y esto hace que no sean nada buenos al tomar decisiones,
y que sean presas fáciles de conductas riesgosas.
Pero, si la culpa es del cerebro que no ha madurado,
¿por qué los jóvenes son más vulnerables que los niños,
si sus cerebros están más desarrollados?
Además, no todos los adolescentes del mundo toman riesgos del mismo nivel.
¿Existen otras causas subyacentes o no intencionales
que los lleve a correr riesgos?
Esto es exactamente lo que decidí investigar.
Basé mi investigación en el proceso psicológico
conocido como "habituación",
o más conocido como "acostumbrarse".
La habituación explica cómo el cerebro se adapta a algunas conductas,
a las que se expone repetidamente, como mentir.
Este concepto me inspiró a diseñar un proyecto
que determinara si se puede aplicar el mismo principio
al imparable aumento de riesgos que corren los adolescentes.
Predije que la habituación a correr riesgos
puede, potencialmente, cambiar el cerebro ya vulnerable del adolescente
atenuando, o incluso, eliminando
las emociones negativas asociadas con los riesgos,
como el miedo o la culpa.
También pensé que, al sentir menos miedo y culpa,
la insensibilización los llevaría a correr más riesgos.
En resumen, quería hacer una investigación
para responder una gran pregunta:
¿por qué los adolescentes corren riesgos tan grandes
que son perjudiciales para su salud y bienestar?
Pero había un gran obstáculo en mi camino.
Para estudiar este problema,
necesitaba adolescentes en los que experimentar,
laboratorios, dispositivos para medir la actividad cerebral
y profesores que me supervisaran y me guiaran durante el proceso.
Necesitaba recursos.
Pero estudié en una secundaria de Dakota del Sur
con escasas posibilidades para la investigación científica.
En la secundaria había atletismo,
banda, coro, debate y otros clubes,
pero no había programas de CTIM o mentores para investigaciones.
Y la idea de que los estudiantes
investigaran o participaran en una feria de ciencias era impensable.
Simplemente, no tenía los ingredientes
para hacer un plato digno de un chef.
Estos obstáculos eran frustrantes,
pero yo era una adolescente terca.
Y como hija de inmigrantes de Bangladesh
y una de los tantos estudiantes musulmanes
en mi secundaria de Dakota del Sur,
muchas veces luchaba por encajar.
Y quería ser alguien que pudiera contribuir con algo a la comunidad,
no ser tan solo la chica morena que usaba un pañuelo
y que era una anomalía en mi homogénea ciudad natal.
Esperaba que, con la investigación,
pudiera establecer esto
y la importancia de la investigación científica para jóvenes como yo
que no encontraban su lugar en otro sitio.
Con unas oportunidades de investigación tan limitadas,
la creatividad me permitió superar obstáculos aparentemente imposibles.
Me volví más creativa para trabajar con varias metodologías,
materiales y sujetos.
Transformé la modesta biblioteca de la secundaria
en un laboratorio
y a mis compañeros, en ratas de laboratorio.
(Risas)
El entusiasta profesor de geografía,
que también es el entrenador del equipo de fútbol,
terminó siendo quien me animaba,
y luego se convirtió en mi mentor para firmar el papeleo necesario.
Y cuando fue logísticamente imposible
usar un electroencefalograma de laboratorio,
o EEG,
que son esos dispositivos con electrodos usados para medir la respuesta emocional,
compré un casco EEG portátil con mi propio dinero,
en vez de comprarme el iPhone X,
para lo que ahorraban muchos de los de mi edad.
Finalmente, comencé la investigación
con 86 estudiantes de mi secundaria de entre 13 y 18 años.
En la biblioteca, usé los cubículos de las computadoras,
donde completaron una simulación de toma de decisiones computarizada
para medir su conducta de toma de riesgos comparable con las del mundo real,
como el exceso de alcohol, el consumo de drogas y las apuestas.
Los estudiantes usaron el casco EEG
para completar el test 12 veces durante 3 días
para imitar las repetidas exposiciones al riesgo.
Un panel de control en el casco EEG
midió las diferentes respuestas emocionales,
como la atención, el interés, el entusiasmo, la frustración,
la culpa, los niveles de estrés y la relajación.
También valoraron sus emociones
basados en escalas validadas para medir emociones.
Esto significó que había medido el proceso de la habituación
y sus efectos en la toma de decisiones.
La investigación se completó en 29 días.
Y luego de meses de redactar propuestas frenéticamente,
computando datos meticulosamente en un aturdimiento por cafeína a las 2 a.m.,
fui capaz de obtener mis resultados.
Y los resultados mostraron que la habituación a correr riesgos
podía cambiar el cerebro de un adolescente al alterar sus niveles emocionales,
causando así que tomara más riesgos.
Las emociones de los estudiantes, generalmente asociadas con los riesgos,
como el miedo, el estrés, la culpa y el nerviosismo,
así como la atención,
eran altas cuando se expusieron por primera vez al simulador.
Esto limitó sus tentaciones e impulsó el autocontrol,
lo que evitó que corrieran más riesgos.
Pero mientras más se exponían a los riesgos por medio del simulador,
sentían menos miedo, culpa y estrés.
Esto generó una situación
en la que ya no eran capaces de sentir
los instintos naturales del cerebro de miedo y precaución.
Y como son adolescentes y sus cerebros no se han terminado de desarrollar,
las conductas que buscan emoción les interesan y entusiasman más.
¿Cuáles son las consecuencias?
No tenían autocontrol para tomar decisiones de manera lógica,
corrían mayores riesgos
y tomaban más decisiones perjudiciales.
Así que no podemos culpar solo al cerebro en desarrollo.
El proceso de habituación también juega un rol importante en la toma de riesgos
y en la escalada de riesgo.
Aunque el deseo de riesgo que tienen los jóvenes
es, en gran parte, el resultado de los cambios estructurales
y funcionales asociados con el cerebro en desarrollo,
la parte peligrosa que pude resaltar con la investigación
es que la habituación a los riesgos
realmente puede cambiar físicamente el cerebro del joven
y hacer que corra más riesgos.
Entonces, es la combinación del cerebro adolescente inmaduro
y el impacto de la habituación
lo que genera la tormenta perfecta para crear efectos más perjudiciales.
Esta investigación puede ayudar a que los padres y el público en general
entiendan que los adolescentes no ignoran las advertencias voluntariamente
o desafían a los padres adoptando conductas cada vez más peligrosas.
El mayor obstáculo que enfrentan es la habituación a los riesgos:
todos los cambios funcionales físicos, detectables y emocionales
que conducen, controlan e influencian su deseo desmesurado de correr riesgos.
Así que sí, necesitamos políticas que ofrezcan ambientes más seguros
y limiten la exposición a altos riesgos.
Pero también necesitamos políticas que reflejen esta percepción.
Estos resultados también son un llamado de atención a los jóvenes.
Les muestra que el miedo y la culpa, necesarios y naturales,
que los protegen de situaciones peligrosas
se adormecen cuando eligen conductas riesgosas repetidamente.
Con la idea de compartir estos resultados con otros adolescentes y científicos,
llevé mi investigación
a la Feria Internacional de Ciencia e Ingeniería de Intel o ISEF,
una cumbre de más de 1800 estudiantes
de 75 países, regiones y territorios,
que exhiben sus innovadoras investigaciones e inventos.
Es como las Olimpíadas de la feria de ciencias.
(Risas)
Allí pude presentar mi investigación a expertos en neurociencia y psicología
y obtener comentarios valiosos.
Pero quizás el mejor momento de la semana
fue cuando los resonantes altavoces, de repente, dijeron mi nombre
durante la ceremonia de premios.
Tal era mi incredulidad que me pregunté
si no era otra metida de pata como la de "La La Land"
en los Oscar.
(Risas)
Afortunadamente, no lo era.
De verdad había ganado el primer puesto
en la categoría "Ciencias Sociales y de la Conducta"
(Aplausos)
Demás está decir
que no solo estaba emocionada por este reconocimiento,
sino también por la experiencia de que la feria de ciencias reconozca mi esfuerzo
mantenga viva mi curiosidad,
y fortalezca mi creatividad,
perseverancia e imaginación.
Aunque esta imagen de estar experimentando en la biblioteca de la secundaria
pueda parecer normal,
para mí representa una especie de inspiración.
Me recuerda que este proceso me enseñó a correr riesgos.
Y sé que eso puede sonar increíblemente irónico.
Pero corrí riesgos y me di cuenta
de que las oportunidades inesperadas suelen aparecer al correr riesgos,
no de los peligrosos o negativos que estudié,
pero los riesgos buenos,
los positivos.
Cuanto más riesgos tomé,
más capaz me sentí de tolerar mis circunstancias poco convencionales.
Eso me ayudó a ser más tolerante, resiliente y paciente
para completar mi proyecto.
Y estas lecciones me llevaron a nuevas ideas
como: lo opuesto a correr riesgos negativos ¿también es cierto?
¿Correr riesgos positivos puede escalar con las exposiciones repetidas?
¿La acción positiva genera un funcionamiento cerebral positivo?
Creo que ya tengo la idea para mi próxima investigación.
(Aplausos)